I pretty much accepted that we wouldn't summit.
But then when we got to the summit,...
...I don't think there's words to describe it.
It was just this feeling of being so small in something so vast.
Congratulations!
For the last two years, I've basically been a full time wheelchair user.
It started about five years ago.
I was having some balance issues and some chronic pain.
I think like everyone else, I was expecting it to go away.
It wouldn't go away.
And so I tried to start finding answers.
Even to this day, still haven't able to tell me exactly why.
The big moment for me on the hike came when we reached this final summit ridge...
...and we had about a quarter mile of steep,...
...sort of treacherous rock between us and the summit.
...and the wheelchair couldn't go any further.
So we had to abandon the chair.
And one of the team members volunteered...
...to help carry Nerissa to the summit on his back.
And together they summited in that fashion.
It was one of the most amazing things I've seen...
...and the people on the mountain were completely blown away.
It was incredible to feel someone else kind of being your legs through that.
If you can be creative and it's something that you truly want to do,...
...then there's a way to figure it out.